I am bankman freed he's the CEO of the
cryptocurrency exchange FDX executive
Sam bankman freed is urgently working to
save cryptocurrency exchange FTX we have
uh you know three billion on our balance
right now we are profitable CX went from
a 32 billion dollar company to
bankruptcy in the matter of just four
days
not too long ago Sam bankman freed it
the founder of FDX was the richest man
under the age of 30. he had a net worth
as high as 27 billion dollars and was
even making moves to potentially acquire
Robin Hood likely the most impressive
part of his success though was that he
was one of the few billionaires that was
able to maintain a relatively positive
Public Image popular Finance YouTubers
like meet Kevin and Andre Jacob
Financial education Jeremy and even
Graham Stefan constantly pitched FDX as
the go-to crypto exchange they described
Sam as a philanthropic hippie who just
wanted to help people and I fed into
this perception as well while I've never
done a sponsorship with FDX or anyone
else for that matter I did post a rather
pause the video about sambankment
exactly a year ago and let's just say
Sam was a great at playing this
philanthropic monk roll he didn't live
in some sort of California state with
this fellow Tech billionaires instead it
he lived in the Bahamas with 10
roommates and drove a Toyota Corolla but
likely the most appealing feature of Sam
for many was what he was planning to do
with all of his money from the very
beginning Sam admitted clear that his
primary goal with making money was to
give it away he lived by this ideology
of earning to give which was no doubt
extremely popular with the masses but at
this point Sam doesn't exactly have much
to give because the vast majority of his
fortunate literally got Thanos snapped
in fact Forbes estimates that Sam is no
longer even a billionaire and the vast
majority of his net worth today at
likely it actually comes from his Robin
Hood stake but how did things you turn
so quickly well let's just say that Sam
went from promising to about everyone
with his philanthropy to needing an 8
billion bailout himself for FTX now to
be clear FDA says that only the
international branch of FTX is under
stress and that the U.S branch is fine
but take that for what you will
according to Forbes FTX is now worth
zero Sam's trading firm at Alameda
research is worth zero and ftx.us while
at the time of making this video they
say its valuation is unclear but by the
time you're watching this this could
very well be zero as well so here's how
Sam bankman went from being the crypto
Superstar who made it 27 billion dollars
in four years to losing 94 of his net
worth in a single day
foreign
if you've only been following media
headlines ftx's liquidity crisis likely
came as a surprise one day FDX was one
of the most trusted crypto changes in
the world and the next day they suddenly
needed a bailout but in reality the FDX
situation has been developing for years
and can be traced back to the origins of
the company if we take a look at why Sam
founded FTX in the first place we'll see
that it wasn't due to a strong belief in
crypto or Bitcoin in fact Sam is pretty
neutral on crypto as a whole the reason
he started FTX was because he saw
opportunity you see it before FDX Sam
was a traditional Wall Street
Professional working at a trading firm
called the Jane Street Capital there he
specialized in trading International
ETFs but in 2017 he spotted an
opportunity to trade something much more
profitable Bitcoin at the time there
weren't dozens of crypto exchanges that
were all super well funded and had
millions of users each most people who
were into crypto prefer to keep the
majority of their Holdings in Cold
Storage wallets and they've only used
exchanges to buy and sell crypto this
led to relatively low volume across many
exchanges leading to discrepancies in
prices on one exchange Bitcoin might
cost ten thousand dollars while on
another it might cost ten thousand one
hundred dollars if you are willing to
buy it on the first exchange it
transferred over to the second and then
sell it you'd instantly profit 100 on
every Bitcoin you bought and that this
is exactly what Sam set out to do with
this first company Alameda research
after about a year of doing this he
realized that while Arbitrage trading
itself was quite profitable the real
money was made by the exchanges who were
earning 50 or 100 per Bitcoin without
taking on any of the risk that Sam was
so in early 2019 Sam set out to create
his own crypto exchange FTX but there
was one major issue he needed money
fortunately for salmon there were plenty
of UC firms who were desperate to get
into the crypto space including some
Heavy Hitters like SoftBank tiger Global
and even Blackstone this has allowed FDX
to raise an impressive at 1.8 billion
dollars over the past four years Sam
would turn around and spend this money
on developing The Firm acquiring other
crypto companies and most importantly
social media marketing they must have
spent hundreds of Millions on marketing
because they were everywhere all the
time and when you have so much exposure
you're bound to get customers whether
you're good at it or otherwise now I
don't think that Sam was a bad per se
but it does seem apparent that Sam was
in it for the opportunity more than the
crypto itself which is not exactly what
you want to hear we've seen time and
time again at massive engineering
companies and detect Giants whether it
be Intel bowling and even apple fall
flat on their face due to leaders who
didn't quite have the technical
understanding or belief in the product
and if that's the case with these
juggernauts it's not surprising that
it's the case with FTX but not believing
in Chris though was just the first of
ftx's issues
you would think that running a brokerage
is relatively straightforward if you
have customers you charge customers a
fee for connecting buyers and sellers
and it's as simple as that if FTX just
stuck to this they likely wouldn't have
run into any issues at all but as you
might have guessed brokerages often get
greedy and look from creative ways for
generating extra Revenue in the case of
FDX this can be traced back to two risky
practices the first of which being a
non-cash collateral whenever you have
cash laying around at a bank brokerage
or really any financial institution for
that matter it's rarely kept as cash
usually the institution will take the
cash and invest it to generate more
Revenue they figured that only a very
small portion of their customers will
actually be withdrawing money at any
given time so they keep some cash
collateral for this but the rest gets
invested usually most traditional
institutions are forced by law to keep
this collateral and cash but when we're
talking about crypto brokerages located
in the Bahamas the rules aren't as clear
Sam decided that it was a great idea to
keep this money not in US Dollars Euros
pounds or even Bitcoin he decided to
keep this money in a token that FTX
themselves created called FTD for the
longest time this seemed like a
brilliant play Given that the ftt token
had rallied from just a few dollars to
seventy dollars but the thing to note is
that such tokens not only outperform
Bitcoin to the upside but also to the
downside and let's just say Bitcoin
hasn't been performing so well this
itself likely added significant pressure
onto Sam's companies but the real crisis
didn't come until people started
pointing this out on the internet for
obvious reasons FTX customers started to
feel a bit uneasy with FTX storing so
much money in the ftt token and the nail
in the coffin came when bayan's founder
sees he announced that they were going
to liquidate on love their FDT within
the next couple of months this
essentially sparked a bank runner on an
FDT causing FDT to fall back to where it
started meaning that fgx's collateral
was now worth a lot less ideally FTX
should just be able to sell their
Investments and to make up for any
discrepancies in withdrawals but that
brings us into their second risky
practice which includes highly volatile
leverage Investments usually financial
institutions investor reserves into
highly liquid safe Investments like
money market funds bonds and mortgages
in the past we've seen that even that
can lead to issues so it's no wonder why
using these reserves to engage and
leverage crypto trading at led to issues
and the worst part about all of this is
that Financial stress often operates in
negative feedback loops when customers
hear that a given institution may be
illiquid they get scared and it would
rather money this leads to the
institution truly becoming illiquited
even if they weren't deliquated before
and given that most of the influencers
who pitched FDX are not telling
investors to withdraw their money well
if everything else didn't already cause
a financial crisis at FTX this
definitely did and let's just say it's
bad it's 8 billion dollars bad
if the 8 billion deficit didn't convince
you that the FTX situation was bad just
listen to what Sam had tried to do Sam
was so desperate to get a bailout that
he approached his biggest competitor
finance and asked them to buy a FTX out
at first binance agreed as this seemed
like a slam dunk Finance was already the
largest crypto brokerage by far in terms
of trading volume and acquiring FTX
would just further solidify their
position but it just took one look at
ftx's balance sheet for binance to
realize that this company was something
that they'd like to stay far far away
from binance would make an official
statement that they would not pursue the
FDX acquisition due to mishandling of
customer funds and alleged U.S agency
investigations and that brings us to
where we are today with the same
scrambling to put together 8 billion
dollars would just by no means an easy
feat even for FTX here's the thing even
at the peak FTX was only worth 12.3
billion dollars so Sam is essentially
asking investors to pay 66 of their Peak
valuation just to bail out the company
who knows how much more money they'll
need to survive this Exodus of customers
from an Investor's perspective it makes
no sense to pay so much money and
voluntarily take on such a massive
gamble in fact existing investors are
already doing the exact opposite by
writing off FTX as a complete loss
Sequoia for example sent out a letter to
their Partners stating quote based on
our current understanding we are marking
our investment down to zero dollars and
if you can to convince existing
investors who already have skin in the
game to invest more money and save their
investment and it's gonna be virtually
impossible to convince anyone else so
personally I think it's just a matter of
time until FTX does officially go
bankrupt if they haven't already by the
time you're watching this and even if by
some miracle they survive you probably
don't want to be keeping your crypto at
an institution that doesn't even believe
in crypto and now has a history of
mismanagement
whether FTX does end up collapsing or
not you can bet that Regulators are
going to use the situation as
justification to crack down on the
crypto industry and honestly that's
probably for the best there's a reason
that bangs and traditional brokerages
are regulated so heavily and it's
because if they aren't it usually leads
to end customers like you and me being
hurt we've already seen two brokerages
collapse this year Celsius and a voyager
and the FTX may just be an addition to
that list and the truth is while I'm
sure Sam is devastated that his company
is on the brink of collabs and that his
net worth has crumbled from 27 billion
dollars to not even a billion and it's
not like anything really changes for him
he still has a seven and a half percent
stake in Robin Hood and unlike FTX Robin
hooded actually has cash in fact Robin
Hood has 10 billion dollars in cash and
their cash reserves are literally worth
more than their market cap so and it's
more than likely that Robin Hood it will
survive this recession and to see the
light of day at which point Sam will not
only become a billionaire again but a
multi-billionaire and even a Deca
billionaire the ones that are truly left
holding the bags are ftx's 5 million
customers or just 3.5 million customers
and Celsius is nearly 2 million
customers I mean it these three
companies alone will have affected over
10 million people and that's just the
people affected by their direct Fallout
if we include indirect effects it's
likely tens of millions more and if
crypto really is the future it appears
to me that regulation is a must but
that's just what I think do you agree
comment that down below also drop a like
if you hope FTX customers get their
money back and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest for everybody ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]